you
hello and welcome from the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences where we've
discovered who's been awarded the 2009
Nobel Prize in Physics joining me to
discuss this year's prize is Professor
Joseph Nordgren chairman of the Nobel
Committee in physics professor Nordgren
thank you very much for joining us so
soon after announcements being made
could we begin by you telling us who has
been awarded the 2009 Nobel Prize in
Physics the price is divided in two
parts and one is goes to Charles tau for
his major contributions to the
development of the optical fiber for
Killah communication and the other half
is shared by two Willard Boyle and
George Smith and they have invented the
CCD sensor that is in this case sheer
invention and as we said in the
announcement these are two achievements
that of affect our everyday lives they
affect the way that it communicates
everyday and in facts the reason why we
can broadcast this announcement live
around the world is down to these
achievements could you say a bit more
about that the practical achievements
that we're discussing towards this
producer price well the the practical
achievements are enormous I mean if you
start with a with an optical fiber for
telecommunication there was an awareness
of the potential of optical
communication in more than 50 years ago
but it was not possible because the
fibers that were available didn't work I
mean after 20 meters most of the light
was was gone and to solve these problems
that was the key work of how that made
all these things happen he was able to
identify what the problem was
really and devise a pathway to a
successful fabrication of the fibers
that eventually led to what we have
today and now I think it's more than a
billions of kilometers of fibers around
the world that connects us all almost
instantly and this is due to the work of
how the work that inspired and started
the
evolution of optical communication that
we had today the other yeah the other
part to record images directly
electronically I mean we had of course
TV cameras the vidicon type of camera
when when Boyle and Smith did their work
and actually they were not primarily
after a sensor to record images they
were inspired or or pushed almost by
competing activities in the lab because
at Bell Labs the bubble memory the
magnetic bubble memory was something
that people worked on and it would be
very important and somehow I think Boyle
and Smith felt a little bit pressed to
come up with some things I could compete
that could could offer something in with
respect or memories so they were
actually trying to invent a new type of
memory but in doing that they soon
realized that they had an image sensor
that worked perfectly well and this is
the form of a image technology that we
see in everyday digital cameras well not
every day digital cameras because in
telephones for instance those cameras
are typically another technique but in a
really high-end cameras where resolution
and sensitivity are really very high
then you'll find the cccd technique so
the prize is rewarding the the use of
fiber optics to communicate information
throughout the world one form of which
is images which was an invention created
by Boyle and Smith yes it's in in this
case it is really an invention and the
idea they come up with the idea and
sketched it and come to a more or less
final solution in a fairly short time
how he worked for for several years very
methodically to try to find out what
were the critical materials questions
what were the typical or the critical
light propagation properties and he came
up with conclusions that set off quite
some activity in order to try to realize
and fabricate these fibers so if we
focus on that half of the prize first
you said that the fiber optics are
already in use but they're they they
weren't great at transmitting light
through through the optic cable
themselves Cal spent a while trying to
work out what was what was missing what
was wrong with these fibers spent a few
years work on this and came up with with
a paper in 1966 to propose what he
thought was was was wrong with these
Gothic fibers how to improve their
quality could you discuss a little bit
about what findings he came up with and
how they were actually realized well the
main thing was that he realized that
there were impurities even though they
thought they had very clean glass it was
impurities that impeded the the
transmission and to get rid of because
he could he made theoretical
calculations the studies and he came to
the conclusion that it should be much
better than it was experimentally and
also he studied what would be the the
showstopper so they're limiting factors
the real showstopper was impurities but
also the other limiting factors is
scattering and excitation in the fiber
of the atomic motion and and so on they
are the things that set their limit
eventually but to get ultra pure fibers
and that was also quite some undertaking
to do that I mean that were others like
Corning Glass that were able after four
years to fabricate such fibers and they
were very advanced chemical methods that
they had to develop and employ in order
to do that so that was also substantial
and an important work that was done by
these glass companies so improving the
quality of the glass that's or in cases
these fiber optics and allowed better
performance allowed less light to be
lost as you transmit the signal through
them what was then possible once these
new use of generation or fiber optics
being created
well the cow had set up a target and
that he thought would be enough to make
communication feasible but the companies
they after four years were able to beat
that target and even go much further but
today of course when the fibers
themselves have something like 95% of
the light is still there after one
kilometer but of course if you want to
communicate between continents you still
lose quite a lot so in today's network
fibre network there is also integrated
lasers you can make a laser in a fiber
so part of the fiber is a laser that
amplifies so you have a number of those
amplification stages also that are used
in today's fiber networks and so what is
it possible to achieve now with with
fiber optic technology well you can
communicate the terabit per second range
and you can have tens of thousands and
thousands of telephone calls in the same
fiber and then sort of the the capacity
of the transferring information is
enormous and and it's still it's still
expanding and so the you decide to give
half the prize to George George cow for
his achievements now there have been
major treatments before in fiber optic
technology and major achievements
afterwards by awarding one half the
prize to his landmark paper in 1966 as
there is the academy saying that this
was the key moment this was the Eureka
moment that allowed fiber optics to to
leap a generation to get to the stage
where we are now yes and these are very
good cases because the nobel prize is is
not really given to lifetime
achievements and somehow common
knowledge
suggest that why didn't he or she get
the price did so much in her life and
his life but the Nobel Prize we want to
award that to singular really decisive
papers or work and in this case the
invention I mean that's clear they made
the invention and it was there and also
cows work he worked for a number of
years and then he published his paper
and you can really see when things and
then you can see afterwards the impact
what happened when once this was done
its set of such an enormous development
so that's the first half of the prize if
we go to the second half of the prize
where we set before that through fiber
optics we can communicate text and
images and videos throughout the world
in the blink of an eye and the second
half the prize is rewarding the the
technology that was created to allow us
to create digital image and transmit
them through fiber-optic technology
could you talk us through the
achievements that will add voice and
George Smith created in allowing us to
create and send digital images well
first the CCD cameras they were used
scientifically and that it made very
very big difference in spectroscopic
instruments but in astronomy I mean in
order to photograph stellar objects the
universe which we can do of course when
we can learn satellites but we need to
send it back it would be really awkward
if we would have photographic film and
and somehow send that back to earth for
development or or or as paper printouts
so in order to be able to record images
with really high resolution and high
sensitivity electronically and just send
it by radio down is of course a
fantastic achievement and and much of
what we have learned over the many
decades several decades at least
from from space missions and the
investigations the Hubble telescope is
of course a brilliant example the the
pictures we see from the Hubble
telescope is made of a giant CCD
detector with really very high quality
and we are all amazed about those
pictures that we can see from the
universe and this for something that's
so familiar in in everyday use and it's
quite surprising to find out that this
wasn't this was developed from a
brainstorming meeting between the two
scientists reward the prize could you
say something about that place isn't it
isn't it amazing that that's and that's
it's so inspiring and fascinating that
that's something like that can happen I
mean they had a somewhat different focus
what they wanted to accomplish and then
they soon realized it could you be used
also for this other application but we
heard in the interview here with dr.
Boyle he said that at Bell Labs at that
time they had a lot of resources they
had an environment which was very
productive and creative and they can
sort of do what they wanted and there's
so much that came out of this lab and
other labs who had that kind of
possibilities unfortunately I would say
into the 80s or so several of those lab
these American labs from but the big
companies had like Bell and Exxon and
and IBM and others they abandoned some
of this these ideas to have a fairly
free possibility for scientists to work
on their problems and that's a pity I
think and of course Bell Labs is no
longer with us but is it is the idea is
the concept of the way that these ideas
come about something that the Academy
really wants promoting in terms of its
overall message yes absolutely
I mean it is the scientific environment
where students researchers work is is
almost everything I mean of course it
has to be based on good and your
education and good basic training but
the environment where your work is more
than than
more important than most other things
and we may not always be so good at
creating the really creative and free
scientific environment so I think the
message from dr. Boyle here in the
interview it's something we should
really listen to and think about also
when it comes to how we plan our
scientific endeavors at universities and
Institute's and how we distribute money
what what what we require from the
researches in order to try to help
building better and more productive or
creative I would say more creative
scientific environments it's great
message to sell if we look at the prizes
that are being rewarded today the the
the achievements were done in the mid to
late 60s and the prize is being given in
the year 2009 is there any particular
reason why in recent years there's been
a compelling case given to rewarding
these researchers now yes according to
the statute a prize that is owned it
should have there should be some some
reason that some actuality should appear
and I think everyone
you really realize I mean for every one
of us the impact of this the work that
is awarded with these two prices this
price Shadwell between two is so evident
for everyone I mean the way we are
connected today the way the
communication works the way we
can image things that happen and we can
transmit easily I mean it is so evident
and that was not evident 20 years ago
and in terms of the the way the prize is
shared is it straightforward decision to
award half the prize to each of these
subjects well you can choose under there
again the statute allows you to share
the price or to divide it into two to
two parts and we thought that it was a
good combination I mean they are linked
to their different distinctly different
but they are linked to each other and it
was we're very happy that we could do it
in this way it is it telling particular
story I think it is I mean these are so
important which are cornerstones in the
information communication society we
live in today and have you had child
speak to all of the new laureates not
old unfortunately dr. Smith we were not
able to find and we don't know maybe
he's out sailing I don't think so but he
is a keen sailor and and he's known to
be sailing but hopefully hopefully the
we had been able to contact him now but
we couldn't just before the press
conference and were were were the tuner
is he did contact surprised to hear the
news yeah yeah yes yes
and of course this is a long time ago
and and they were but they were really
very glad of course for this pleasure
Norgren thank you very much for
discussing this with us thank you for
more information about 2009 Prize in
Physics please visit Nobel Prize org
where you can already see the official
background information to the prize and
soon you'll be able to see exclusive
interviews with the new laureates that's
about it for this webcast but join us
tomorrow where you can discover who will
be receiving the 2009 Nobel Prize in
Chemistry the announcement scheduled for
11:45 Central European Time but until
then it's goodbye from all of us a Nobel
Prize org